ja mein vortrag knüpft an den begriff
der aufklärung an den begriff des
politischen wir schon in vorherigen
vorträgen thematisiert wurde ich möchte
heute besonders auf dem bild des senders
kommunist fokussieren der bislang wie
mir scheint noch nicht so im
zusammenhang erörtert wurde
ich gehe zunächst auf das problem einer
dialektik der vernunft ein dann widme
ich mich geben theoretischen vernunft
teilen der begriff des vermögens wird
eine zentrale stellung einnehmen meinem
vortrag dann auf das praktische vernunft
das betrifft das gesamte vermögen danach
kann dann abschließend komme ich zum
eigentlichen thema dem sensus communis
dem ich als eine form von politischer
vernunft verstehe da gibt es ein bezüge
zur urteilskraft und der in meinen augen
diese problematik des vernünftiges die
in unsere fünft angelegt ist löst eben
auf eine politische weisen dass es so
die grobe gliederung ich beginne mit dem
allgemeinen problem der dialektik der
vernunft kette das müssen sie alle
dieses zitat kann sagt wir sind als
individuelle endlich vernünftige wesen
unausweichlich von einer dialektik
getroffen die kant auch seine kritik der
reinen vernunft als logik des scheins
bezahlt was ist mit dieser logik des
scheins mehr auf sicherheit werde ich
gleich versuchen zu analysieren
jedenfalls geht dass diese dialektik
gleichermaßen und seinen theoretischen
wie praktischen gebrauchte von uns
betrifft
ihr grund der grund der dialekt besteht
darin dass wir als endlich vernünftig
gewesen den hang haben die normativen
grenzen unserer theoretischen und
praktischen luft zu besteigen
indem wir uns durch eine logik des
scheins das ist die dialektik darin
rechtfertigen und gegen kritik
immunisieren hier haben wir dann auch
wie ich später noch versuche zu zeigen
in bezug zum aufklärungs aufsatz zu
kannst begriff der aufklärung
die individuell zurechenbar aktivität
dieser dialektik hatte dieses aktiven
zurechenbare erzeugen von das bezeichnet
kant als vernünftig hier gibt es schon
einige studien dazu martin sticker hat
dazu gearbeitet
page hat dazu gearbeitet mit dem blick
wirklich aufs böse und ich habe hier
auch noch einiges um jüngster zeit
veröffentlicht also der begriff des
vernünftigen ist zentral es komme ich
auf das theoretisch eröffnung zu
sprechen nach kannten müssen wir
zwischen vernunft schließen und
vernünftigen schlüssen theoretischer
hinsicht unterscheiden kann spricht von
vernünftigen schlüssen in dem sinne dass
ist sophie kationen sind nicht der
menschen sondern der reinen vernunft
selbst von den selbst der weisesten
unter allen menschen sich nicht los
machen und vielleicht zwar nach vieler
bemühungen sind wird schon verhüten den
schein arbeite im unauflöslich zwackt
und äfft niemals für dich nur werden
kann es geht also wieder richtung dieser
aufklärung dieser unmündigkeit die nicht
einzelne betrifft sind die eine
generelle tendenz unserer
vernünftigen zitaten diesem zusammenhang
es gibt also einen natürlichen
unvermeidliche dialektik der reinen
vernunft nicht eine in die sich etwa ein
stümper durch mangel an kenntnissen
selbst verwickelt oder die irgendein so
fest und vernünftige leute zu verwirren
künstlich ersonnen hat sondern die der
menschlichen ist ohnehin betrieblich
anhängt hier wieder diese natürliche und
unvermeidliche allgemeine kritik die
alle flüchtigen wesen gleichermaßen
betrifft jetzt gibt es verschiedene
formen des scheins kann sagt wie gesagt
die dialekt ist die logik des scheins
und gibt es verschiedene formen von
scheinen die unterscheiden muss erstmal
dem empirischen schein geht steht durch
einfluss der einbildung auf unsere
urteilskraft wenn wir etwa durch unseren
sehsinn getäuscht werden das eigentlich
gerade oder unter wasser als zum nothin
geboren geknickt wahrnehmen dann gibt es
im logischen schein der besteht als
schein der trugschlüsse in der bloßen
nachahmung der vernunft formen und man
kann privat ive als einen mangel
achtsamkeit auf die logische regeln bzw
mangel an kenntnissen stimmt und das ist
auch nicht der volks sinn von schein im
dialektischen sinne es gibt nämlich auf
dem transparent ahlen scheinen und der
ist gegenüber dem logischen schein nicht
einfach ein begehbarer mangelzustand
unsere erkenntnisse mögen der beruht auf
einem hang unseren selbst insofern ihr
grund regel und maxime ihres gebrauchs
legen welche kennt sich das ansehen
objektive grundsätze haben und er darin
seinen grund hat das zitat die
subjektive notwendigkeit einer gewissen
verknüpfung unserer begriffe für
objektive notwendigkeit gehalten wird
also in der dialektik in der luft
bescheid wird subjektive schein haft für
das objektive erklärt und das ist eine
aktivität die eben nicht nur privat ihf
zu verstehen ist sondern die zurechenbar
sind ja auch eine gewisse form von
vernunft eben voraussetzt und das ist
gerade das vernünftig wie ich noch im
frühjahr zeit möchte im transplantat
schreibende die fürsten maßlos da
hierbei nicht nur kategorien auf einen
gegenstand falsch angewendet werden sind
wie mir die bedingung der möglichkeit
einer einsicht in ihre fehlerhaftigkeit
durch die erzeugung einer korrekten
scharfen worten verhindert wird da sie
sich selbst immunisiert das ist dieses
subjektiven für objektive halten und
zwar aus gründen da wird vernünftiger
werden gründe angeführt man spricht auch
von einem vernünftigen
geli um armut hans der darin besteht
heterogene vorstellung die oft nach dem
gesetz der einbildungskraft der
assoziation weit auseinanderliegen zu
assimilieren also für sich nach eigenem
gutdünken corinth zurecht zu legen denn
hilft das von eltern es komme ganz
verschiedenen kontexten und kann es mir
vor und zwar eben auch im praktischen
der grundlegung zur methode 17 sprich
kant einem zitat mächtigen gegengewicht
gegen alle gebote der pflicht welches
der mensch in sich fühlt dem dir eine
praktische fünf du hier unten diverses
und kategorisches geboren die
individuellen bedürfnisse des doubs
zurücksetzt entspringt aus diesem
gegensatz einem bekannten endmärkte
welche dialektik die kann doch als ein
zitat hang wieder jene strenge gesetze
der pflicht zu vernünftig bestimmt wer
vernünftig der versuch nach kant gründe
zu finden seine individuellen interessen
alles der absoluten vorrang des gesetzes
ausnahmsweise zu rechtfertigen also die
reinlichkeit und strengen moralischen
gesetze in zweifel zu ziehen und sie
womöglich unseren wünschen und neigungen
angemessener zu machen das ist sie im
grunde zu verderben hier findet also
eine aktive aktiver gebrauch der
vernunft statt aber eben im moralischen
sinne
hier gibt es noch einen anderen begriff
der sehr zentrale ist im kontext des
verwünscht und nämlich der eigenen
dunkel der schreibt kann auch als einen
hang die auch das fünfte des menschen
wieder lehne strenge gesetze der pflicht
zu vernichten und ihre gültigkeit in
zweifel zu ziehen dieser hang besteht
darin sich selbst nach dem subjektiven
bestimmungsgrenze zur objektiven
bestimmung skonti des teams überhaupt
und zur obersten praktischen bedingungen
zu machen
und jetzt komme ich auf den eigentlichen
gegenstand eines vortrags zu sprechen
nämlich auf dem sensus kommunen es als
politische vernunft
die dialektik der vernunft hat nämlich
auch eine politische dimension und nicht
nur eine systemische und einem wal
philosophische kann sagt nämlich so wird
der hand sich dieses vermögens zum
vernunft zu beginnen nachgerade
methodisch und zwar bloss durch begriffe
zu vernichten das ist philosophieren
darauf sich auch politisch polemisch mit
seiner philosophie an anderen zu
schreiben das ist zu diskutieren und
weil das nicht leicht ohne effekt
geschickt zu gunsten seiner philosophie
zu zeigen letztlich im masse
gegeneinander schule gegen schule als
hiergegen hier vereinigt offenen krieg
zu führen also das vernünftig das kann
auch ansteckend wirken
und jetzt lässt sich unser hang zum
vernünftigen im sinne der
selbstverschuldeten unmündigkeit
beziehungsweise zur natur gewordenen
unmündigkeit verstehen kann begriff der
aufklärung enthält einen dem privat even
vernünftig entgegengesetzten
öffentlichen vernunft gegriffen sagt
nämlich zu dieser
aufklärung aber wird nichts erfolg als
freiheit und zwar die unschädliche unter
allem was nur freiheit heißen lag
nämlich die von seiner vernunft allen
stinn allen stücken öffentlichen
gebrauch zu machen also die das private
vernünftigen ich habe es falsch gesagt
dass private verhaftet das soll
vermieden werden indem die vernunft
nicht individuell gebraucht wird wir
geben sie dann zum vernünftigen führt
nämlich dem sie zu öffentlichen gebrauch
animiert wird der gemeinde das heißt der
öffentliche menschenverstand der sens
des kommunisten als bedingung der
möglichkeit einer vermeidung des
vernünftiges geräten und das möchte ich
jetzt noch zum schluss genauer zeigen in
seiner kritik der urteilskraft die
bekanntlich ja sein gesamtes kritisches
geschäft abschließen sollte führt kann
drei maximen des gemeinen
menschenverstandes den zensus communis
an die er in seiner logik auch total
regeln und bedingungen der vermeidung
des irrtums überhaupt nimmt das sind die
folgenden ersten selbst denken zweitens
angestelle jedes anderen denken und
drittens jederzeit mit sich ein ständig
denken in eurer nähe hat in diesem
zusammenhang von einem verdi charakter
für windeck herchen friesen und eine
politics aufwiesen gesprochen weil sich
sehr zutreffend findet also hier finde
hier wird die vernunft nicht privat
sondern
öffentlich gebraucht und wie ich jetzt
eben versuchen zu argumentieren dadurch
auch zu einer art gegenmittel gegen
unseren hang zum vernünftigen
beschreibe jetzt die kurz kurz nach die
regel die kante gibt halte die erste
regel die kann auch als die maxime des
verstands bezeichnet die bezeichnet als
die maxime der vorurteilsfreien ging
und auch die maxime niemals passieren
zukunft und eine passive vernunft
versteht kann die metronom ideen
vernunft beziehungsweise das verurteilen
und den aberglauben der darin besteht
sich die natur regeln welche der
verstand ihr durch sein eigenes wesen
das gesetz zum kolleg als nicht
unterworfen
vorzustellen kann bezahlen in diesem
zusammenhang die befreiung vom
aberglauben auch als aufklärung als die
aufgeklärte maxime verweist sie direkt
auf ganz beantwortung der frage was ist
aufklärung daran hat erkannt bereits die
unmöglichkeit des menschen als selbst
verschuldet seien und diese ausdrücklich
nicht am mangel des verstandes
festgemacht seiten der individuelle
entschließung des objekts kann seines
sondern unvermögen zugeschrieben landes
vernünftigen die verkannt beanstandete
selbstverschuldete unmündigkeit
gegründet wie ich sowieso zeigen daher
muss der plus individuelle gebrauchte
vernunft wird diese vernünftige
missbraucht zu einem allgemeinen dh
öffentlichen gebrauch erweitert werden
der der tendenz zur selbst immunisierung
durch die logik des scheins durch die
dialektik vorbeugt die zweite maxi mit
sein kann deswegen als die maxime der
urteilskraft bestimmt sie als erweiterte
maxi mit das heißt als vermögen der
inter subjektivität
zitat sich in andere gesichtspunkte im
denken zu versetzen diese maxime ist
ausdruck einer erweiterten denkungsart
und darin besteht darin sich über die
subjektiven privat bedingungen des
urteils wird zwischen so viele andere
wie ein geklammert sind wetter setzen
und aus einem allgemeinen standpunkte
wenn er dadurch nur bestimmen kann dass
es sich in den stand vom antrag bis
jetzt über sein eigenes urteil zu
reflektieren also wir haben eine
politische dimension öffentliche
dimension die eben eine art eine art von
ausbruch aus diesem individuellen
abgeschlossenen form des vorstands steht
die dritte maxime nennt kann die
konsequente oder bündige denkt hat der
auch als die maxime der vernunft
bestimmt kann betont dass diese am
schwersten zu erreichen sein wenn wir es
jetzt die ersten beiden maximen bereits
voraus zitat kann auch nur durch die
verbindung beider ersten und nach einer
zur fertigkeit geworden öfteren
bevölkerung das feld erreicht werden als
ich ja schallte es nicht nur eine art
und kapitalisierung zu handeln ihre
funktion kann darin erblickt werden dass
das e6 mit sich selbst einen inneren
dialog eintritt und aufrichtig und
kritisch sein unternehmen befragt es
geht also darum dass man mit seinem
urteil sowohl in sich selbst konkurrent
ist also in ein interner subjektives
gespräch eintritt sich selbst außen
reflektiert und sich eigene einwände
macht diese drei maximen die kann in der
kritik der urteilskraft es auch in
seiner logik nimmt die konstituieren in
ihren zusammenspielten sensors communis
logik sind kann auch als zutat idee
eines gemeinschaftlichen kindes das ist
eines beurteilungs vermögens bezeichnet
gegen jede der maxime auf ein
menschliches erkenntnisvermögen bezogen
ist das betonen kann bedeutet der sensus
kommunist die gelungene koordination der
menschlichen theoretischen wie
praktischen bekenntnis und damit in
politisch öffentliche hände geben auch
die einheit von ganz gesamte kritik da
sie ihm auch diese theorie in der kritik
der urteilskraft getreten enthalten ist
die einheit von kants kritik der
erkenntnisvermögen wird also nicht ihrem
gelingen deutlich sondern da wo sie zu
scheitern drohen durch den zensus
kommunist ist gewährleistet dass ich das
vernünftiges objekten stand versetzt
sieht zitat gleichsam an die gesamte
menschen von uns sein urteil zu halten
und dadurch die illusion es ihm gehen
die aus subjektiven privat bedingungen
welche leicht vor objektiv gehalten
werden können eben vernünftig auf das
urteil nachhaltigen nachteiligen
einfluss haben wird
die sensus kommune ist wird dadurch
reduziert zitat dass man sein urteil an
anderer nicht so wohl wirklich als in
der bloß möglich hält und sich in die
ställe jedes anderen versetzten die man
bloß von den beschränkungen die unsere
eigene beurteilung zufälligerweise
anhängt abstrahiert diese abstraktion
des gemeinen menschenverstandes führt
dazu dass man ein zitat die formalen
eigentümlichkeiten seiner vorstellung
beachtung finden soll so dass man ein
urteil sucht welche zu allgemeinen
regeldienst ebendieses die forderung des
kategorischen imperativ nach universal
kite welche nun aber in ihrer antike
elektrischen wirkungsweise sei es im
theoretischen wie praktischen vernunft
gebrauch neue perspektive wird und
fruchtbar gemacht werden kann die
öffentliche gebrauch der vernunft
impliziert im letzte händigt also eine
politische dimension und die perspektive
durch einige gesellschaft reform die
dialektik der zwölf zu vermeiden indem
die selbstbezogene individualität einer
freien gesellschaft des gebens und
nehmens von gründen die sich auch medial
und institutionell manifestieren kann
beschrieben wird vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit zum schluss nur ein paar
literaturhinweise wohl dem thema noch
weiter nachgegangen bin einmal neue
aufsatz der erscheint bei theorie und da
habe ich das war schon ein bisschen noch
näher betrachtet und auch auf den
zusammenhang des theoretischen und
praktischen
täuschungsversuch bin ich auch noch mehr
eingegangen
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit und
ich bin gespannt auf die diskussion